Deku finally returns in the manga and
his fight against shigaraki is Raging
furiously but there's a serious problem
Deku can sense that all might is dying
all might continues to battle the
overpowered all for one as he prepares
to sacrifice everything for Deku and the
Next Generation this chapter was so dark
and yet so wholesome at the same time so
exciting and yet so tragic and we need
to talk about it you guys know the drill
if you enjoy my mha content you want to
see more in the future leave a quick
like and comment right now to help me
out with that YouTube algorithm and if
you're one of the over 50 of people who
watch my videos but haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet we are getting
close to that 2 million subscriber Mark
so now is the best time to subscribe and
be a part of that epic goal finally this
video will contain mhmaga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned in the previous chapter the
epic battle between the ever younger all
for one and Mecca all might escalated
even further all might showcased more
incredible abilities that his special
armored suit possesses in an attempt to
Rattle all for one mentally and distract
him from his main mission which is to
reach shigaraki almight has been using
Yang over one's emotional instability in
order to get him to take his Focus away
from shigaraki and the strategy seems to
be working all might began outright
mocking his opponent on multiple
occasions and all for one seems to have
taken the bait since at one point he
like randomly activated six different
quirks at the same time causing a
massive explosion there wasn't
necessarily a logic to using these
specific six quirks at the same time it
seems that all for one is kind of losing
it and the rage is leading him to just
explode with different Quirk Powers now
you might think that rattling all for
one a bit isn't really a big deal but as
we learn in the latest chapter this
might actually turn out to be crucial
for the outcome of the fight it seems
that the more power all for one uses the
faster he is rewinding himself out of
existence and all my strategy seems to
be goading all for one into using as
many quirks as possible in Rapid
succession which will hopefully lead him
to rewind himself out of existence
before he has a chance to reach
shigaraki in the last chapter we saw a
quick flashback of young quirkless
toshinori seeing Pro Hero Nana shimura
in action as she took down a bunch of
villains despite being just a quirkless
student toshinori also wanted to help
defeat the villains by attacking them
with a metal pipe which surprised Nana
since this scene reminded me so much of
the moment that all might saw a
quirkless Deku trying to save bakugou
from a villain I speculated that this
could be the very moment that toshinori
Anana met for the first time the latest
chapter seems to confirm my speculation
because we begin with young toshinori
following Nana as she walks away and
asking her to make him her disciple so
yeah it seems like this is the first
time that the two of them met and it was
because of this meeting that toshinori
eventually became her disciple people
and inherited one for all just like Deku
the fact that toshinori was willing to
risk his life to fight against villains
despite being quirkless is what led to
the current holder of one for all to
notice them and take an interest in them
toshinori continues to ask Nana to
accept him as her disciple but she says
no because he is worthless she tells him
to just take that metal pipe and go
protect his own family but almight says
that his family was killed long ago
presumably by villains or criminals Nana
says that hers was too but she maintains
that she doesn't have time to help some
kid exact his revenge for the loss of
his family so here we learned that all
might's parents were seemingly killed by
villains when he was quite young and
this surely must have played a role in
his decision to try and become a hero
despite the fact that he is worthless as
far as Nana goes we know that she lost
her husband to all for one but I'm not
sure if this is the family member that
she is referring to or if there are even
more members of the shimuna family who
were killed by villains now now even
though Nana made it clear that she has
no time for Revenge fantasies toshinori
keeps pushing and he explains that he is
not interested in Revenge he cannot
stand the Dreadful state of society
criminals and villains get rewarded for
their actions which creates sorrow and
blind rage and victims eventually
turning them into criminals as well
toshinori doesn't want to just stand by
as this spiral of crime hatred and
sadness consumes the hero Society he
wants to create a world where everyone
can live happily with a smile on their
face and for that to happen this world
needs a symbol a symbol of peace there
is far too much crime and villainy and
people are traumatized and living in
fear so toshinori wants to become the
symbol of peace someone that older
people can look to for protection from
all the evils currently plaguing Society
someone who will always be there to
offer them hope and a sense of safety
Nana is clearly moved by these words and
she obviously does believe that toshin
Tony is being sincere but she still
wonders why he would be pursuing that
kind of power when he doesn't even have
a quirk toshinari replies that in this
chaotic situation most people are busy
just trying to protect their families
and they don't have time to worry about
grander ideas like becoming the symbol
of peace for an entire Society but
toshinori is someone who doesn't have a
family and who doesn't have a quirk he
doesn't have a role of his own in this
Society so he wants his role to be the
symbol of peace this is quite an
emotional moment and you can really see
the dedication and sincerity in
toshinori's face as he is saying all of
this to Nana Nana clearly sees it too
because she did eventually agree to
become his master and she eventually
transferred one for all onto him
toshinori became all mind the symbol of
peace back in the present moment
almight's car Hercules fires off a
strange high-tech projectile which
smashes right into all for one's abdomen
this projectile appears to be like a
giant high-tech syringe and it in inject
all for one with a strong acidic
substance all might names the attack
after Mina ashido AKA pinky so we can
assume that maybe she provided the acid
for this syringe as all for one's body
begins to take damage from the highly
potent and corrosive acid entering his
body all might mocks him again in the
last chapter all for one had referred to
all might as garbage but look who's
rotting now all for one and all might
continue their battle and they
eventually crash violently into Tatooine
station tsukauchi and the police are
worried that the fight is coming
dangerously close to the UA but
thankfully all might is still managing
to keep all for one busy and away from
shigaraki and Deku in fact after more
Fierce fighting all might finds himself
on top of the very same roof that he and
Deku had been on top of in the first
chapter back when Deku first asked
almight if he could become a hero
despite being quirkless now even though
all might have been doing a fantastic
job holding off all for one and keeping
him distracted he he has still sustained
some serious injuries during this battle
his armor is damaged all over he has
broken ribs and other injuries across
his entire body and even his respiratory
system is beginning to malfunction but
even though he is in very rough shape
all might refuses to give up he
remembers how Deku rushed in to save
bakugou even though he was quirkless and
he remembers what Stane said to him
about the role of almight the symbol of
peace within the hero society and so
almight gets to his feet and he faces
all for one one last time after all the
Man known as all might could not live
his life any other way as the villain
flies above all might the hero notices
that all for one has gotten even younger
if he was like a teen earlier now he's
closer to a tween and it's clear that he
doesn't have very much time left all for
one was forced to use multiple quirks at
once at a very high intensity in order
to get all that deadly acid out of his
body and so the result is that he
suddenly became visibly younger so all
might concludes that the more damage
over one takes and the more that he is
forced to overuse his quirks the quicker
he will remind himself out of existence
all might then not only smiles as he
usually does but he even laughs heartily
while important moments from his life
flash before his eyes many of these
moments involved Deku all might
successor and the symbol of peace for
the Next Generation all might calls out
to Hercules to send everything they've
got at all for one right now and then he
proclaims that he's happy to play this
role and to help everyone he is happy to
be the symbol of peace once again even
if it turns out to be the very last time
interestingly enough we see that the
white color has returned to all might's
right eye while his other eye remains
that sunk in dark color all might vows
to do his best and to win or rather he
seems confident that in the end the
heroes will win but there is no
guarantee that all might himself will
live long enough to see that Victory as
all the remaining weapons and support
items are activated all at once all
might armor grows a bunch of extra
appendages kind of like Doc Ox Tentacles
from the Spider-Man franchise there is
also like a robotic drone that looks
like a bird flying above all might kind
of like a mini tokoyami the hero
activates additional abilities in order
to increase his Mobility including
abilities that were inspired by his
students in genium and uravidi and while
all might is preparing for his last
stand against all for one the Vestige of
all might within deku's one for all
suddenly feels the presence of the real
almight the Vestige can sense that all
might and all for one are fighting and
then after many many chapters we finally
get another glimpse of the epic battle
between Deku and shigaraki both of them
are looking absolutely Fierce and like
they are fighting furiously but Deku is
also concerned about all might since he
can also sense what almight's Vestige is
sensing the final page of the chapter
features all for one looking down on all
might as almight thinks about Deku
referring to him as young midoriya
midoriya Shonen almight's overwhelming
determination has reached Deku and
throughout this chapter all might has
been truly incredible and inspirational
he refuses to give up despite severe
injuries he is fighting bravely and
boldly until the end and throughout it
all he firmly believes that the heroes
will win in the end however even though
this chapter is very hopeful in many
ways they are also very dark undertones
in this chapter that we definitely need
to talk about in the previous chapter I
mentioned that there were a lot of death
flags for all might but in this chapter
that is taken to a whole new level we
got the full flashback of all might's
first encounter with Nana and how he won
her over by telling her that he would
sacrifice everything to to become the
symbol of peace we saw clearly that all
might is seriously injured and yet he is
still pushing himself to keep fighting
all for one in fact he is even having
respiratory issues and blood is spewing
from his mouth so that is certainly not
a good sign we saw important moments of
his life flash before his eyes as he
laughed these are major major death lags
and if all might is ever going to die in
the mha manga then this is the time if
all might sacrifices himself right here
and now in order to prevent all for one
from reaching shigaraki it would be both
a symbolic heroic sacrifice and a way
for him to pass the torch to the Next
Generation after all even if all might
can take all for one down with him
shigaraki will still be out there so
that means that all might is still
trusting Deku and the Next Generation to
bring the fight to an end after he is
gone and with almight's Vestige noticing
that he is in trouble I can definitely
see this being the end for both all for
one and and all might just think about
it the symbol of peace may die right
here now but then his Vestige inside of
one for all will finally be complete it
will no longer be just a silhouette of a
Vestige it will be all might's Vestige
in its full form just like the other
vestiges and with that all might will
continue to live on inside of Deku just
like Nana and the other former users of
one for all and Deku will become the new
symbol of peace after he defeats
shigaraki and brings the war to an end
honestly this mha final Arc hasn't been
perfect although it has had some great
moments but depending on how horikoshi
handles all might's potential final
sacrifice this could turn out to be the
most epic and most powerful moment in
the entire series I don't know about you
guys but I'm both scared and excited to
see what happens next what do you guys
think are these death Flags
foreshadowing all might's final
sacrifice will almight's death change
the nature of his Vestige inside of one
for all is Deku about to become the new
symbol of peace let me know down in the
comments below for more foreshadowing
about all might's potential death don't
miss my previous video link in the
description and on screen if you enjoyed
this video and you want to see more mha
content in the future leave a quick like
right now and if you're one of the over
50 of people who watch my videos but
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a big favor and subscribe right
now we are trying to fully awaken our
Quirk here on the channel by reaching 2
million subscribers and every single
subscription helps